all right why don't we start with this
Ben 10 x to the 2x the concept is that
it's easier to grow 10 times than it is
two times well if you're gonna go for 2x
growth in anything what that means is
that mostly I'm operating from my past
2x is very linear it means that you're
using the past to dictate who you are in
the present and what you're going to do
in the future and if you're going for 2x
growth because it's linear you don't
really have to change that much we
actually use the 80 20 principle or
model to kind of highlight these
differences so if you want to go for 2x
growth you can actually keep 80 of your
life you can keep 80 of your strategy 80
of your clients 80 of your time can be
spent on the same things you only have
to change 20 of what you're doing just
as an idea so 10x is going to be the
opposite 10x is where you imagine a
seemingly impossible future you think
about a future and a bigger future a
seemingly impossible future and you use
that future to dictate your strategy not
the past so the past is going to dictate
a 2X strategy the future is going to
dictate a 10x strategy the more you go
10x it's about quality not quantity so
on a daily basis rather than trying to
do 10 things you say what are the one or
two things that are going to have the
biggest impact this is me going deep in
my 20 this is where I'm going to get a
bigger return on my attention rather
than me trying to do 50 things in a day
I start thinking about bigger things
higher quality less quantity I start
thinking what's one or two things I
could do today they're going to pay me
long term in the future this is deeper
work this is growth
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us movement makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip I am super excited to be joined
here by Dr Benjamin Hardy author of this
amazing book 10x is easier than 2x this
is my favorite book of the year I was
just telling Ben a little bit about it
we didn't go into too deep because I
wanted to share live with you guys here
so we're going to talk about how to 10x
your business some of the lessons I
learned some of the things I'm still
struggling with as a result of reading
this book I don't know if you can see I
have like massively marked up this book
so almost every like second or third
page there's some note there so I get I
get sent a lot a lot a lot a lot of
books from a lot of friends and
sometimes you have to read a book
because it's from a friend and the book
is you know it's an okay book but this
is legit a great book my favorite book
of the year so we're gonna have a quick
conversation about 10x and how to 10x
your movement in your business and then
we're going to get to some questions
from you guys all right why don't we
start with this then 10x D then 2x the
concept is that it's easier to grow 10
times than it is two times which feels
like a a brain twist right like that's
not possible so why don't you give us
the people who aren't familiar with the
concept why that's possible what it
means so I'll share a couple tidbits and
as we go on the idea will sink deeper
and deeper it's like I can't just give
you algebra in 10 seconds but I'll give
you the taste of it and then as we go
deeper and deeper and deeper it's going
to become you know more thoughtful so
let me explain the difference between
10x versus 2X and this is one of the
reasons why I love working with Dan is
is that he he helps you kind of think in
terms of opposites right so we wrote who
not how as an example and so he helps
you think about focus on who don't focus
on how right and so a lot of people talk
about 10x but they've never actually
contextualized it where they've
described its opposite and in this case
we're describing the opposite of 10x as
2X and so what are the two differences
between 10x and 2x just as a start well
if you're going to go for 2x growth in
anything call it you want a 2X your
YouTube subscribers as an example right
or 2x my book sales for me what that
means is that mostly I'm operating from
my past 2x is very linear it means that
you're using the past to dictate who you
are in the present and what you're going
to do in the future and if you're going
for 2x growth then you because it's
linear you don't really have to change
that much we actually use the 80 20
principle or model to kind of highlight
these differences so if you want to go
for 2x growth you can actually keep 80
of your life you can keep 80 of your
strategy 80 of your clients 80 of your
time can be spent on the same things you
only have to change 20 of what you're
doing just as an idea so 10x is going to
be the opposite 10x is where you imagine
a seemingly impossible future and by the
way all of you if you really look at
your life you've accomplished this into
time even going from crawling to walking
is a 10x seriously where you kind of
went from one stage of being to another
and at that new stage where you're now
walking you've let go of your old self
you're no longer going to go back to
crawling half the time you're going to
stick with walking and now you have new
freedoms and new potentials at your new
level so 10x is really about going to
another level but to do it you operate
from the future you think about a future
and a bigger future a seemingly
impossible future and you use that
future to dictate your strategy not the
past so the past is going to dictate a
2X strategy the future is going to
dictate a 10x strategy and this is where
it gets kind of interesting and so this
is where it'll start to we'll start to
go into the flow of how it starts to get
easier
there's a lot of research on this that
if you start making your goals a lot
bigger Higher Goals have a lot less
options so I'll I give an example of my
son who's a tennis player my son's a
freshman tennis player he you know we
live in Orlando Florida so tennis is a
big deal there
my son is a freshman in high school and
he wants to play college tennis right so
I want you to think about this in
Orlando where we live there are hundreds
and hundreds of coaches and academies
that could probably get my son to the
college level
do you think there are more or less
potential paths to getting from college
or getting to Pro if you decide to go
for pro so here we go there are less
options to go for for the higher goal
would you say that's right
so if you make the goal 10 times bigger
it immediately weeds out the 80 percent
right so so this is where it starts to
become the opposite that to go 10x you
actually have to let go of 80 of your
life right now and go all in on the 20
that really matters and over time you go
deep on that 20 which is the effective
stuff and if you go deep on that stuff
you're going to get a lot bigger return
and and so 10x simplifies things it
helps you find the few Pathways that
matter
um so for my son as an example it would
actually be easier for him
to to find a positive useful strategy if
he was going for pro rather than College
because then we'd have to find the few
coaches in Orlando that could
potentially get him there he'd have to
really become aware of the few aspects
of tennis that really matter from the
pro level whereas if he's just going for
college he's going to keep a lot of
aspects of tennis that aren't going to
be that effective for him does that make
sense so Higher Goals weed out all of
the 80 that doesn't matter it simplifies
your process we can go into a lot more
obviously if you go for Higher Goals
you're gonna have to get better teams
and stuff like that but I think that's a
good start for now what do you say no
that's great I like it so what I loved
about your book is we've heard the
concept of hey you got a 10 extra goals
think bigger a dream bigger
entrepreneurs change the world Etc which
is great and inspiration sure what I
loved about yours is it's it's tactics
of how to break it down and the hardest
one that I'm still wrestling with is you
got to let go of 80 of the things that
you're doing there you go so if you want
to just double you can you let go of 20
percent of the things that you're doing
and improve them or tweak them or
whatever but if you wanted to go 10x you
have to like you have to let go of 80 of
the things that you're doing right and
so as I'm reading this like I feel I
feel the you know the stress to like oh
my gosh you're not gonna let go of and
and looking backwards you have this
great exercise like hey look back and
realize you've already made 10x leaps
right and so if I look back well we've
I've already let go of a lot of stuff
we've got 52 people on staff now right
so like I've let go of a lot of things
but if I had to analyze
how do I let go of 80 of the things that
I'm currently doing right now
uh there's a lot of pain or resistance
or even identity built down under like
doing the work and so I read the book
and I'm getting excited like oh okay
okay I start making my list and then and
then I wake up tomorrow and I find
myself back into doing the work that I
was there well so why do we stay high at
that level so the 80 represents your
past cell right it's what got you here
it was useful but it no longer has the
the same juice to squeeze as that you
know it doesn't have 10x potential
anymore it may have in the past right
something that was once in your 20 that
you got a lot of value and use out of at
some point once you really grow it might
shift down to your 80 and it's no longer
relevant so like I give myself as an
example when I was a first year PhD
student I I might quote unquote my 10x
future self and by the way the core
analogy of this book is Michelangelo
Michelangelo who sculpted the David one
of the things that the pope asked
Michelangelo was what is the secret
behind how you made the David and maybe
you've heard it before but he said I
took away everything that was not the
David right I Stripped Away everything
that was not the day but have you guys
heard that before your 10x future self
is the David and you've got to strip
away everything that's not the David
and so that's your 80 and that's your
past self that's your psychologist who
would call that your hidden commitments
these are things you committed to in the
past and they were useful so like as an
example for me back when I was uh a grad
student I had zero blog zero website I
just really wanted to be an author and
my quote unquote 10x feature self was to
be a professional author with one of the
major Publishers I was also just brand
new foster parent of three kids you know
and I wanted to um you know provide for
my family and be a professional author
so I want to get a six figure book deal
with one of the major Publishers so one
of the nice things you can do if you're
letting the future be the filter Which
shapes that 20 is I would ask a lot of
professional authors and stuff like that
how do I how do I get a six figure book
deal in this case and they're like well
you got to start blogging you gotta
actually build an email list all that
stuff you know you gotta get really good
at blogging good at communicating good
at writing so that identified my 20 that
I had to go all in on and get 10 times
better at you get 10 times better before
you go 10 times bigger right and so I
had to let go of a lot of 80 for example
I had a job as a graduate student 20
hours a week that not only you know gave
us a little bit of an income but it also
allowed the university to take away my
cost of tuition and so after that first
year of PhD school
um I got really serious about my 10x
future self and the 20 that I was gonna
have to go all in on to get really good
that means I had to let go of my
University position and start paying for
our own tuition
scary that was a massive risk
um but you know to kind of go back to
your question so 80 represents security
right it's your security blanket not
only is it maybe the aspects of your
business or your job that you're already
really good at or just that are in your
comfort zone but they're also your
habits right they're the things that you
do on a daily basis it could be just
hopping online and just scrolling when
you're bored right it's your 80 that's
honestly holding you back it's your past
self but it's not your future self and
so it's your security blanket and
your 10x future self is freedom which
takes commitment and courage you don't
strip it away all at once by the way
like you strip away or uncommit to your
80 little by little you become a lot
more honest about your future self a lot
more honest about where you're going to
start going deep and start really
focusing on what you want and on what's
going to have the biggest impact and
inevitably it's going to have it's going
to require you to
um let go of various relationship
situations maybe clients um like me for
example I am letting go of my coaching
program this year this is my last year
doing it and it's like 80 it's like 60
or 70 of my income right now totally
letting it go because I know it's part
of my 80 even though right now it's
great security and right now it's great
I know if I keep it it's going to keep
me from fully committing to my next 10x
and so I'm willing to let that go even
though sometimes sometimes it's harder
some things are easier to let go of some
you know you got toxic friends or
something like that where it's like yeah
this is my 80 like I don't you know
there's no anger towards those past
friends you know love them just like you
love your past self and you honor them
but they're no longer in the direction
you're going so some things you can let
go of easier some things the more and
more you start connecting and
identifying with your future self the
more organically eventually you're just
gonna let it go it takes time how do I
maintain the
commitment and courage this is why I
love micro dosing on on books because I
get a little bit of Ben every week you
know I get I get a little bit of like
the 10x mindset every week
when you're reading the book or maybe
kind of even hanging hanging out here
with Ben you're meeting him for the
first time perhaps you get inspired
motivated how do you maintain that you
know because it's an identity shift is a
habit shift it's a it's a way of
thinking shift and so you can get these
moments of these boosts of
excitement and like yes here's what I'm
trying to do and build and create and
then it's so easy to fall back down
tomorrow and not stay committed to the
cause yeah so I look at 10x like a 10x
psychology as three things it's
fundamentally three things it's one it's
your identity two it's your time which
is really about your attention and then
three it's your leadership and and we
can go into all three of these but you
know just going into
identity for a second your identity is
two things it's your story and it's your
standards it's the story you have about
your past self and the story you have
about your future self and so one thing
that I think about you could do uh Evan
is
more and more your story becomes less
about what you've done and more about
where you're going right who's your
future self start being a lot more
honest about that start being a lot more
honest about where you're going to go
deep and about you know what you're
going to be focused on like that story
is going to shape your priorities
um in terms of Standards because I said
identity is two things it's story and
standards your standards is essentially
your floor and your ceiling right but
it's also whatever you're focusing on
and whatever you're committing to so
like one of the things that I do is I'm
always trying to raise my floor right my
floor like the elements of my life that
are still in my 80 so like am I and part
of my floor might be that um you know in
just being honest if I'm looking at my
day that I you know still consume all
sorts of trash food right or I I spend
spend three hours of my day doing X
that's totally a waste right and that's
just part of my floor all progress
starts by telling the truth and so I
could raise that floor a little bit week
by week you don't you don't go 10x
tomorrow so every week you can start to
shape your story how can I how can I
operate more today as my My Future Self
versus my past self
um you know well aspect of my floor can
I raise where I'm focused on quality
over quantity so this takes me to uh
time and I'm just going to tell you two
aspects of time one is your attention
and the second one is flow so you can
start to shape your week around being in
flow in your 20 and this is this is not
about what habits you can put in place
to get into a flow State I think that
that's kind of 2x thinking honestly it's
about how you can refine and reshape
your entire calendar and schedule around
your 20 so as an example and also
honestly just about being in flow the
more you go 10x it's about about quality
not quantity so on a daily basis rather
than trying to do 10 things you say what
are the one or two things that are going
to have the biggest impact this is me
going deep in my 20 this is where I'm
going to get a bigger return on my
attention so rather than me trying to do
50 things in a day I start thinking
about bigger things higher quality less
quantity I start thinking what's one or
two things I could do today they're
gonna pay me long term in the future
this is deeper work this is growth but
also you start you know actually having
more time for recovery and thinking
because if you're going to go for bigger
leaps it's not about busyness it's about
actual like impact and so that means
you're going to have to have more time
for recovery and thinking if you think
about any high level performer recovery
is a big part of that LeBron James
he's one of the best uh athletes of all
time if you actually study his process
most of it's around recovery
you know space if you recover well then
you can go deep when you're actually in
practice or you know getting ready to
like get better at your craft go deep in
your 20 so I'm gonna I'm gonna simplify
this for you guys real quick for Evan
whatever your 10x is whatever it is
you're trying to accomplish certainly
you know it would be good for you to
think about who's your future self like
what does that 10x look like and start
designing your days and weeks and months
around you being more in that story and
more in that and that's going to
emphasize like now let's look at your
calendar and where can we shape it
around you being more and more in the 20
and how can we peel away some of that 80
maybe you'll let eliminate some of it
over time that would be raising your
floor or maybe you apply who not how
which would be the leadership side where
you start getting someone else to handle
that so that you can spend more and more
of your time going deep in whatever your
20 is maybe it's you writing a book
right maybe it's you whatever it is that
you want to go 10x at
um and your time starts slowing down and
you have less and less honestly when you
go 10x and this is the last thought on
it your time is less thinly sliced it's
less scattered so you're probably not
going to have meetings every day you
know like you want more days for deep
blocks for deep thinking deep work deep
breath unless for some reason or another
your 10x invites you to have that like
meetings all the time but I think you'd
start stacking away meetings maybe
batching them so that maybe once or
twice a week you have more meetings and
you've got more time for going deep so
that's how I'd start to think about it I
don't know like you tell me now where
where the when the rubber meets the road
that stuff doesn't truly make sense to
you no it makes sense I think it's and
for everybody the your future self is
Ben's last book before hit the 10x book
so when he's referencing that you can go
check that one out as well
let's get hardcore on it for a second
like you talking about it like because I
like with all the mumbo jumbo I just
said how would you apply that seriously
to your own 10x like call it for for the
rest of May yeah how could you redesign
May because if we if you were to take a
hard look at your May I'm guessing that
a lot of it's in your 80 and it might
already be pre-committed to your 80
um
but how you know maybe you could Shuffle
it a little bit so that you have bigger
blocks to going deep on something you
really care about yeah it's it's making
that thought process a daily habit and
maybe even multiple times per day habit
habits are always the byproduct of
calendars and schedules yeah it's so
much easier to start with your calendar
and schedule rather than trying to build
a habit into your pre-existing schedule
so it's so much easier if you start with
design like I look at habits as micro I
look at I look at your schedule and your
life design is macro and it's a lot
easier to change the micro by changing
the macro so rather than focusing on
Behavior which is honestly a painful
process
um you actually just start to redesign
the macro of your life so that would be
like look at take a hard look at your Q2
and like what is your Q2 already look
like that you've already pre-committed
that it's going to be and start to say
honestly how much of this is me into X
mode and like how much of this can I
uncommit to or renegotiate or honestly
let go of or just re-situate so that I
free up a lot more time and a lot more
space if you're going to go 10x you need
a lot more white space a lot more
freedom of thought there's actually a
great quote from Dan Sullivan on this he
says that entrepreneurs who are too
tightly scheduled don't have the space
to transform themselves so in a lot of
ways you have to free yourself from that
um and once you've done that and you've
kind of re-situated your calendar your
schedule uh even potentially your goals
habits become a lot easier to work with
if you're just working on habits
um you're honestly uh I actually look at
that as 2x personally
so we had Stephen Cutler here at the
last uh genius event and he was talking
about flow and Steven's the world's
leading living expert on Flow and after
that meeting I changed my schedule I
agree with you schedule creates the
habits so that I'm walking outside three
hours a day you just changed your whole
habits around changing your schedule
exactly I feel like this needs to be
incorporated into one of the daily
things I'm doing so that it's a it's a
more regular consistent thought not just
on the on the the big things I'm doing
but in the day-to-day like do I still
need to even do this is this still even
as viable like could I Outsource this to
somebody else am I still getting joy and
pleasure from this like it it feels like
at least for me until it becomes second
nature I don't know if it ever becomes
fully second nature but I think it does
I think just put it this way yeah you
right now are 10x where you were at one
point in the past and 100x where you
were at various points so would you say
that your life right now is second
nature to you
your current life yeah yeah your current
life is second nature to you you've
normalized it you've adapted to it even
though if we went back to your past self
who was call it one tenth of where
you're at now in various aspects in
knowledge skills
if your past self was looking at your
current self that would seem like an
impossible Gap and this would not be
second nature to your past self this
would be almost like unfathomable but
because you went deep and you've you
know you've ultimately become who you
are you've now normalized this as your
regular life and so yes it is second
nature to you and so whenever you think
about your next quote unquote big leap
10x jump your next level
um right now it does not seem second
nature to you right now it seems
unfathomable to you but eventually it
will be your second nature and you're
going to be at a 10x place in various
aspects than you are now and a lot of
that 10x is not necessarily quantity a
lot of it's in terms of quality in terms
of value your time is gonna be spent on
things you value more on things that
um you know are are more important to
you and maybe there's 10x quantity there
you know for you maybe you're maybe you
you will be used to having a channel
that's 35 million people and and you'll
have a lot of different challenges and
opportunities and problems with that and
you'll be used to it at that level yeah
you will make it second nature we always
do yeah I mean I guess it's just once
you get there then what's the next 10x
Leaf right so it's like making the 10x
thinking second nature it is a process
so this is a continuous process that
every time wherever you're at right now
you're at a 10x Place compared to your
past self and the question is do you
stick with the 80 security that got you
here as an example so for me
back to my story of 10x you know 10x
author I did go deep on that 20 I I did
become a massive blogger you know my
blogs were viewed over a two and a half
period of time over 100 million times
and I was able to organically literally
organically build an email list of
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
people therefore I got my book deal I
became my 10x features off I'm now at a
different place now the question is from
that new place
I'm now at a different spot than my past
self it's kind of like climbing a
mountain or getting to a new level from
up here I can now view vista's
opportunities new you know new
opportunities that my past self could
never see so now as this you know quote
unquote future self I can see and create
a next 10x that my former self could
have never even imagined but that next
10x is going to invite me into a new 20
a new growth Journey a new development
and it's not going to be about more it's
about going to be about different and
better and so the wagging which was
something I did very aggressively for
three or four years shifted to my 80 and
I had to let it go because it was no
longer relevant to the new deep dive of
Mastery and development when you go deep
into the 20 whatever that is for you
you're going to go into a higher level
of Mastery and development which is
going to by getting 10 times better and
more nuanced and more skilled in what
you do for whoever you do it for
um the 10x becomes very possible
and
and so yeah I would just say and I I
even forgot your question at this point
but
um
you know the things that you've invested
a lot into this is one of the reasons
why it's actually hard
because you gave your soul in a lot of
ways your time your energy your effort
and your identity into whatever you
became and now what you've become you've
normalized and now it's not just your 20
now it's your whole life and so now
you know we're saying you're gonna have
to let go of huge aspects of who you are
or who you were to go deep into now
who's your next 10x future self you know
what's you know using the hero's journey
what's the next Call to Adventure right
and of course the second step of the
hero's journey is is the resistance to
the call right which is then to retreat
back to your 80 security blanket right
and so yeah you can go to the call again
and peel away more and more of the
layers of the onion or of the David and
find out more and more of who you really
are at the purest Essence and the
highest level of mastering contribution
you can make or you can say this is the
level I'm comfortable with I'm happy
with this one eighty percent I'm gonna
stay here and sometimes we stay in that
80 for years and maintain it we'll mold
a lot onto it and sometimes we never
actually go go deep dive uh into our
next level of Mastery so anyways yeah
that's great one of the things I had to
pay attention to is the language like
the language I tell myself uh when we
cross 50 employees it's like 50 people
on our team that's crazy and that's epic
rocking you know when you think about
your past yeah keep going but but then I
realized if that's crazy then I then I
don't get the 500. there you go right
like it's not that crazy this is this is
easy like 500 is not even that crazy
right and so just reframing how you see
where you're currently at and what
you've done yes be be grateful to kind
of happen again be grateful for what
you've done but it's not it's not crazy
and you're capable of so much more so
I've just been paying attention the
language I use around the things we've
accomplished I'll say one more thing
real quick and I feel like you know
these people are just wherever you want
to go Evan but yeah if you're using your
current circumstances as the filter for
what you do moving forward then you're
going to be in your 80 because your
current circumstances are mostly 80
right and so what got you here was using
a very desirable future which at some
points may have seemed impossible to you
definitely to other people and you let
that then be the determining factor for
what you said yes and no two that's you
using the future is the filter that's a
more exponential mindset that's a more
10x mindset that's a higher level
Mastery where you're using your future
self and your future identity and your
future Vision as as the determiner for
what you say yes and no to and what you
filter out and what you start letting go
of and peeling away and so you know it's
an invitation for all of you to look at
your current life and say are you going
2x which is letting your current self
and your current results shape what you
do and what you think is possible you
know so this would be like Evan thinking
50 is crazy or or he can if he wants to
if it's relevant it may not be relevant
think to 500 employees and say what
would need to be true for us to get to
that level if that's even the right
metric maybe he doesn't need 500
employees to get the 10x he wants right
if it's about having 35 million
subscribers that might not require 500
employees um you know you might use that
metric as the determining factor of what
you start saying yes and no two so what
you what you optimize for really matters
which is you know 10xing your employees
is very different than 10xing your
subscribers and they're going to lead to
a different path a different process and
so asking what's what's the 10 X worth
going for and how is that going to shape
what we start saying yes and no to and
what we start going deep on
all right nice to see you I love this
guy so much let's do some Q A's let's
bring up Ronald thank you thank you uh
Benjamin already
a super highway filled with gold for
everyone I've been working on a startup
for a couple years to change the world
uh free Revenue don't need the money God
Bless but my current job is kind of
paying for that
um as I've been spending more time and
having more success launching the save
the world project I've cut back on the
other part of my coaching probably 50
percent
are you saying give up everything and
just take that under 20 hours and
visualize uh like Evan says walking
three hours a day doing the things that
I will do once that project is actually
launched to just
um to step into it and to visualize it
that much more or
because this is the comfort zone
question and I know that this is
probably of course you get it most often
well the three easiest ways for me to
ease off my coaching practice more to
work on saving the world yeah so every
person's in a different situation and
therefore is going to have a different
process of letting that go I'll share
with you a couple different examples and
ultimately I can't give you a perfect
formula because I don't have your
situation I don't have your goals I
don't have you know if you had just as
an example if you had five extra million
dollars just as a thought that might
change your process right and so it
might not I'm just saying if you had you
know I'm just saying I don't know the
full dynamics of your situation but let
me give one example so Brooke Castillo
which you probably know her right yeah
so she talks about and one thing I will
say is
the 80 is going to defend itself very
deeply the 80 you know that that might
be people right that's you know people
on the team who are just honestly not
ready to go 10x with you like they're
going to defend the status quo right
sure ux does not want to change the 80
does not want you to change it once
things to stay the same
um and so even your past self is going
to defend itself
um but one of the things that Brook
Castillo talks about I'm just giving you
an example is she realized as a coach
that she wasn't going to be able to go
to her next level if she continued to do
one-on-one coaching that was just
something she realized and that was
something that her business was
initially built around and so she had to
ask if I want to really get to my goal
which I think at that time was getting
to like 10 or 50 million dollars Revenue
she knew that she could no longer be the
one-on-one coach and so and again this
is a very there's different models and
there's different ways of looking at
this but for her she had to slowly peel
away her being the one-on-one coach and
getting lower level and not lower level
but other coaches to take over that
portion so that she could then like do
things around group coaching and
platform building and stuff like that
and admittedly a lot of her Legacy
clients that were used to her being the
one-on-one coach were pretty upset
because they didn't they you know to
actual defend itself right and she had
to accept that that was part of the
process of her reaching the people that
she now felt inspired to reach and to do
what she so that process probably took
her a year or two to hire on and bring
on other coaches and transition the
clients who were going to continue with
her uh so that she could shift Over You
Know Dan Sullivan's done it a similar
way where he has like multiple levels of
his coaching program and over time he
lets go of those lower levels right so
like there's like the core signature
level he let go of that and he had like
17 coaches who handle that for him
um but this year just like recently he
let go of his 10x program and so he's
now but he gave himself two years to do
that but that took up 180 of his work
days
like that took up a lot of his time and
so if he gave himself a deadline you
know he gave himself a few years to
build up the team the process so that
you know at a certain point he could get
there and now he's let that go and so
you got to ask yourself is this
something you're going to eliminate
altogether or is this something that
you're going to maintain but have
someone else do one of the examples that
I used in the book is from the book good
to great in that book and you'll see it
I think it's in chapter two or three
you know the story of Kimberly Clark the
paper mill company you remember this
story so basically what happened was the
new CEO came in this was back in 1971
but Kelly Clark or Kimberly Clark Paper
Company had been around for over 100
years and the major thing that this
company did was make paper through paper
mills for things like magazines like
paper you know and essentially what the
new CEO did is he took a hard look at it
and he realized that there was that 95
percent of their revenue was in the
paper mills making types of paper that
were sent to other businesses like B2B
right paper for magazines and stuff like
that for printers and stuff like that
but five percent of their business was
kind of on this thing that was more
business to Consumer they had just
created what are called Kleenex right
you guys ever heard of Kleenex and
toilet paper and stuff like that right
and so he realized that he thought from
his perspective we can stay good if we
keep the paper mills but I think we
could become great if we go all in on
this thing that's only right now five
percent of our revenue and he said I
think we should sell the paper mills and
go all in on this thing that right now
is only five percent of our Revenue but
I think we could become truly great
in the long run if we went all in on
this and really mastered this he said I
think I see a potential of world-class
capability here
and this is I think would fit with the
idea of
um of Mastery and even Dan Sullivan has
a concept he calls unique ability but um
basically what do they do
they decided to sell the Mills which was
seemingly business suicide this was 95
of the revenue and what was their bread
and butter as a company for 100 years
and basically he said I'm going to sell
the Mills and everyone thought he was an
idiot thought he was like how could you
possibly do this this is a very
successful powerful company they took
all the money and they went all in on
stuff like Kleenex and stuff 25 years
later you fast forward it's the biggest
paper company in the world
because they went for good or sorry they
went for great
and in that case that was going all in
on their 20
um and they let go of what was the good
so in their case they sold it and just
stopped so there's gonna be different
models for how you approach this for me
as an example I'm just letting go of my
coaching program I'm not gonna sell it
I'm just gonna let it go and I might
create something new with someone else
but in terms of a lot of the stuff I've
been doing for the last five years
chapters over next 10x has invited me
into a new 20 percent
let's go we got James in the house how
we doing James hey Evan I'm good thank
you for this I appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you Dan
congratulations what do you get prolific
so what you did uh willpower doesn't
work it was one of the books that really
connected to me because you described it
as a dangerous fad which is part of this
question so I was going to ask you about
authoring it how you went from this
blogger to being a prolific author but I
think you've kind of answered that can
you talk a little bit about the
Practical steps of removing the 80 of
the blogging or what the practicalities
of that were you talked about
calendaring and scheduling but I'd love
to know a little bit about how did you
become more prolific and I know in your
books you're starting to talk about how
Dan and you are kind of challenging each
other to produce more content that's
going to help people transform their
lives so that's the part A Another Part
B is that
as we think about migrating to our
future self and we have this intention
of identity
of evolving to that identity what do you
think are the dangerous fads now
that's really interesting uh that second
one I'm gonna have to think a lot more
about
in terms of the first one as an example
letting go of the blogging right
um
again from where I was I had to ask
myself what's my next 10x and does
blogging is blogging gonna be in that 20
that's going to support that you know it
forces you to be really Discerning back
to the idea of my son as a college
tennis player right or as a high school
if he wants to go for pro uh he's gonna
have to get new coaches right he's gonna
have to he's gonna have to learn skills
and stuff like that that he would never
have to even think about if his goal was
to stay for college right and so for me
I was like well I wanted to become you
know
less about a big author more about a
really exceptional writing really
important books and so for me you know
obviously selling books mattered and
making an income mattered right
um
but I it wasn't all about building the
audience at that point it was about now
producing work that was a lot harder uh
in the book actually I even shared the
example of James clear because James
Clear went through a similar example
where he was blogger and he had to shift
to a like a a deeper form of work to
write a book it's a lot longer form of a
process to write a a deep really high
quality book than to crank out blog
posts right it's a different type of
work it's a bit a bigger fish you know I
had to get clear what's my 10x for me it
was 10x better author right 10 you know
really good books but for me as well I
like I also do like being prolific you
know I want to write more books but I
also want them to I want to ensure
they're enormously better and so for me
that being the filter to what I say yes
and no to continuing to crank out blog
posts wasn't going to fit that instead I
needed to actually go deep on actually
like studying the craft of writing books
and on honestly like learning how to
storytell and do a lot of developed
skills that I honestly just didn't need
to develop as a blogger like there's a
lot of different skills and deep work uh
that go into writing books and so every
10x is going to invite that 20 which is
a level of Mastery in skill development
and so I ultimately went deep on those
things and it's a work in progress you
know I would say I published willpower
doesn't work about five years ago it was
in it was in March of 20 2018 so it was
five years ago so I would say that over
these last if I was to compare this book
with willpower doesn't work I would
argue that this is a 10 times better
book
um yeah in many different sports yeah
it comes on Tuesday I can't wait yeah so
it's all I'm going to say is I think
I've gone to that process and I would
argue I'm at 10 times better author than
I was from my first book my books are
now approaching a million copies as well
and so now you know I'm in a place where
I'm deeply asking what's my next 10x you
know what's where do I want to go deep
on now that's going to invite me into a
deeper maybe even a more important form
of Mastery than I haven't been paying
attention to now because I've been so
focused on the Mastery that's gotten me
here
because I don't know does that help
Amanda that that's still principal level
but yeah and if I would have kept
blogging I might have done two or three
books right now rather than six but most
importantly I wouldn't have gotten to
the point where I could have written a
book at this level you know let's bring
up Rose she's next let's ask her to
unmute and see what she's got for Beth
okay so me my husband we watch you at
night time on our our YouTube uh
stretching we stretch at night and we
you're on so I'm I'm stuck
super grateful to people you just need a
Ben Hardy stretching video now that's
that's the best thing yeah exactly
yourself you know right
and then you had one about uh meditation
so I thought that you were gonna lead me
to a meditation but you were talking
about manifestation where you said to
write down like think of what you can
achieve like couple of months from now
and and I did and um and you said to
visualize this person I did the first
weekend I I stopped okay you stopped
imagining and thinking of your future
self and you shifted back to living as
your current self day to day yes yes yes
good so what do you have a second
question obviously I can share with you
my thoughts on like the simpler ways and
it's it's similar to what I was talking
to Evan about before but I can answer
that question on like a daily basis
process but do you want to ask your
second question first or you said yeah
yeah so you always you have a lot of
quotes that you uh say when you're
speaking how do you remember them
I don't know I've just been studying
this stuff very intensely for 12 15
years and the things that stick out to
me I write down and I think about deeply
and they inform how I see the world and
so it's not that hard to draw you know
because it's not like it's just an it's
not just an idea it's something I really
deeply chew on and it informs kind of
you know how I see the world and the
choices I make so the quotes that I
share
are usually ones that I've
you know ripped through my brain a
million times you know what I mean so
yeah
um and and uh and I do a lot of writing
and a lot of thinking and also a lot of
teaching and talking into those things
get dotted and connected together you
know from like a neuro neuro perspective
a lot of these quotes are tied together
in certain ways and so when I start
talking about one boom Another just kind
of just pops next to it right because
they're connected to each other you know
in terms of like the neurons and stuff
like that
yeah yeah so here's kind of
how to how to think about your future
self right and this Dan and I did write
the Gap in the game which I think is a
great book on kind of reviewing your
progress but one thing you can do so I I
think it's crucially important at the
end of your day to journal for five
minutes
and actually review the day and actually
look at the day and say how much of that
day was spent as my future self versus
how much of that day was spent just
honestly in my autopilot as my pass up
just kind of roll into the Motions you
could say how much of it was in my 20
how much of it was in my 80 right uh you
could like review that and so I think if
you just reflected for five minutes uh
and then you know at the end of your day
right it's really the end of the day is
so crucial because it really sets the
tone for not only how you're going to
sleep but also what you commit to and
ultimately what you wake up to and how
you operate the next day uh to me it's
it's the most crucial time
and um and it really isn't that
complicated I just think do an honest
review also you could do a bigger term
review if you wanted like look back on
your last year and my guess is that
actually you are a lot more as your
future self then you're giving yourself
credit for you're actually doing better
than you think you are
um but you can still be honest you know
you can still see the areas where you're
still kind of
you know not not operating as your
future self because if you were you'd
start planning different and better days
and weeks but so for me it's really
simple just daily
end of the day journal for five minutes
actually honest review how much of my
day was spent operating as my future
self how much of it was in my 80 how
much of it was my 20. the 80 would be me
you know going back to my past self
being busy not productive uh being
distracted not being purposeful not
being intentional and then I could think
like what's you know how would I what
would a future soft day look tomorrow
what are the most important things I
could do tomorrow that are going to have
the biggest return on on my investment
of time no matter what's important not
urgent you know what are the one or two
things that my future self would have me
do that I can go deep on you know in my
20 maybe it's you know this connects
with flow you know flow can be deeply
focusing on something but it could also
be recovery so maybe it's me spending
more thoughtful time with my kids right
um and so just designing your days but
then at the end of your week design your
week so like review your week for 20
minutes just a weekly review how much of
it was spent as your future self how did
you design it did you design it for flow
so you can go deep on a few things for
focus and Recovery or was it honestly
just pretty not well designed and it was
kind of designed around being busy in
the 80 you know I'm just looking at it
and then saying how can I reset next
week so that it's a little better right
so that maybe it's a little bit more
oriented as my future self right and
deeper in the 20 of things that really
matter and what are some things that
maybe I want to either let go of or
totally re you know recreate right maybe
I've got meetings scattered throughout
the week maybe I could maybe some of
them honestly have got to go
um so I can focus on a few things that
really matter or maybe I could crunch
them all together on Friday or something
like that so that they're all blocked
together so that I've just created a lot
more space for deep work or for honestly
just deep recovery
um so uh I just think it's a day by day
week by week month by month process
um it's not like you you know you try to
just like do it once and lock it in it's
just like every day review how are you
doing is your future self how are you
doing is your pass up tomorrow what what
does your future self want you to do
just do on a weekly basis monthly basis
just continually review and reset
um and it's just it's just continuous
thank you how do you prepare yourself
before your Ted like because uh
like going on stage do you have a
routine or like you jump up and down do
burpees like what do you do I'm usually
by myself you know like I I try to be
alone I usually am listening to like you
know music or good books
um I usually honestly take caffeine uh
just to kind of like get myself focused
um and then I just kind of let it go you
know like you know I honestly just I
mean it's nice to have an outline so if
I'm using slides it's very easy because
I can just use that as kind of like a
you know a stabilizer
um but I think you get better and better
at um not being so attached to a single
performance right so for example like I
want to you know provide as much for you
as I can again Evan makes this really
easy because he's here as well
um but and I I want this to be great but
I'm also not as attached to this one
performance you know like I'm gonna take
it I'm gonna turn into a positive I'm
gonna learn from it hopefully we provide
a lot and just move forward and do the
next you know and just keep moving
forward and so you don't have to for me
at least I don't need to overly hype
overly crank my energy up overly you
know okay I don't need to have such
highs and lows in terms of each one
anymore it's like you know you can kind
of smooth out the process thank you
amazing thank you Rose all right who we
got next we got Milko in the house let's
say you have this vision of your 10x
um how do you go back to know which are
actually the activities that you you
need to do and you need to focus on
because
um I'll give you an example with myself
for example I know what I would like to
do
but the question is uh my actions so far
Kevin bring me
too close to what I do because I I don't
I guess when you go to a higher level
then you kind of uh have better idea
what works and what doesn't so you know
what to focus on and uh stuff like that
or I don't know maybe it's not the case
but the the question is how to know what
exactly or at least the direction of the
things that I need to do to reach this
10x because I have the vision of
how this 10x looks but I have no idea
what they're just because I don't have
the problem with the execution for
example when I have the idea and I I put
things in my schedule I execute but then
I end up in a point that I'm not sure
what's the next step I don't know what
to do next so I just I waste my time
let's say you're wondering yeah so
there's different aspects right like the
path forward isn't always clear and the
path is going to change along the way in
Psychology they call that Pathways
thinking it's not like once you've
clarified the 10x you immediately know
the 20 you're like okay I'm gonna spend
the next three years just
doing this one thing and um it'll all
take care of itself right like you're
all you know sometimes it's you're gonna
figure things out along the way like
you'll you'll do your best to find out
you know and and I love the concept of
reverse engineering so like for example
when I won to become a professional
author I obviously like went and asked a
lot of people who are already there or
who were close or who were you know in
that realm where should I focus where do
I need to like actually put my energy
and attention uh ultimately I'm my own
person I've got my own path every single
person actually is an outlier your own
future self is not going to look like
anyone else's even I'm an author I'm
different than any other author I've got
a different path a different process
like and so you know you can only learn
so much from other people but they can
help point you to the right direction
and you know and so as you clarify your
future self I think you want to think
about a few things you want to think
about what's the situation what are the
circumstances where do you want to be
but also who do you want to be like what
are you actually doing what's your like
what are you actually doing well
um and what kind of impact can you be
having and what like what does that look
like right and so if you start to
clarify the characteristics of your
future self and kind of who you are and
what you're doing I think that that can
start to point you to where you start
developing skills and capabilities like
I think about Evan like you know he's
got so many you know skills that has
passed up probably didn't have in terms
of not only like obviously thinking
through like YouTube and stuff like that
but also like how he teaches how he
trains how he you know so those were
those were things that he ultimately
chose to master because they they were
relevant to where he wanted to go and
where he's continuing to want to go so
it's kind of more to focus on what
they're what kind of person do we need
to become to be able to reach the
Aesthetics I think that's a big part of
it the second part would be then one of
the pathways that are ultimately going
to get you there as an example for me
one of the pathways back when I want to
become a professional author was why I
got to figure out a way to get big you
know a bunch of blog subscribers so that
led me to the pathway of blogging on
YouTube right I could have I mean
blogging on medium.com I could have
easily just as much back then
come to the pathway of creating YouTube
instead I went blogging because I felt
like that was more relevant to the 10x
that I wanted but I could have found a
different pathway a different strategy
different relationships right and so yes
it's a big part of it big part of it's
who you want to become and who you want
to develop yourself into and and stuff
like that but this you know just as
equally or you know
just as importantly as you know what are
the pathways the relationships you know
you're in this group as an example
because you feel like being in this
group is part of the pathway to helping
you develop the skills characteristics
relationships that are going to help you
get where you want to go right so this
is a path right
um and so you also want to think about
you know tactically or strategically
like what is the most likely way you
know and and starting to be honest about
maybe this path isn't working anymore
you know that's part of adapting too is
continuing to adjust to find more and
more useful paths to getting to where
you want to go and sometimes you know a
path that got you a few steps forward
now is leading you to a better path it's
going to get you five steps forward you
know so continually adapting and
iterating along the way too and being
honest is this the most useful effective
process to get me where I'm trying to go
but let me piggyback off this thing no
I'm curious for you so Beth pendell I
did a YouTube session with her where she
was coaching me she's garyvee's life
coach wow okay and you think of garyvee
as being the life coach oh he has a life
coach and so uh I did a session with her
and one of her main things is f the how
yeah there you go uh and she swears you
know I don't but
um and that it's really just believing
and I have not fully embodied this
because I love the plane like I see a
plan I want to invest in a plan how did
you do this let me model your success
plan she's like the big difference
between you and Gary and the people
who've like accomplished even when next
yeah you and 10xu there you go like that
reframe is uh is there's just focused on
that it's possible and that great things
come to you and not so much worried
about the plan and so I am I am uh
definitely not there yet but that's part
of my daily process is like how do I
just live in live in the future live in
future self living great things come to
me live in 10x mode and if you're living
there then the how well so this reminds
me it shows up this reminds me of be to
have if you start being from your future
self right and you start operating from
that identity operating from that level
of acceptance It's not that the how
doesn't show up but that the how is
coming from the operation of of the
result rather than you trying to
strategize from the present towards the
future you're actually operating from
the future and and uh different things
come to you right and so I I mean as a
whole I agree with that that's why I I
would say it's it's you you are going to
have it how though
you know like at the end of the day your
daily process is going to be a how
um but I think continually being open to
um you know a future and not getting so
attached to it how you know like garyvee
doesn't have a how he keeps filming
videos and stuff like that but I think
that the more and more you just start
being as your future self it's it's
certainly going to look different than
what you're doing right now yeah doing
it from the future yeah yeah and and you
also make it easier because you know
you're there's a great quote actually in
the book have you ever read the book as
a man thinketh no I have it yeah yeah
well one of the simple things he says is
we do not attract what we want but Who
We Are
and so when you start operating as your
future self accepting your future so you
go from the layer of thinking to feeling
to knowing so thinking is about thinking
about your future self imagining it
right but then you get to the place of
feeling this is kind of I think where Dr
Joe dispenza's work really is where it's
like you start to emotionally accept
allow be grateful for that right then
you get to the place of knowing where
you know that what you want is already
yours and so once you get to that place
um then yeah you start attracting
honestly you know from that perspective
a lot of the things you want but also
you start to become aware of things you
start to get ideas and insights about oh
maybe I should reach out to that person
right uh you stop being so attached to a
certain habit that doesn't mean that you
don't get ideas that you then go and
execute on yeah um yeah I mean it's like
be be your future 10x self yeah and then
now and then better house will show up
well how is from the future will show up
not house from the in this this goes
straight back to the idea of 10x versus
2x 2x is going to be linear it's gonna
be from the present and past whereas 10x
is going to be more in this operation of
your operating from the future and the
house are going to look exponentially
different because they're coming from a
different future rather than from your
presence so it's not going to be linear
it's going to be very non-linear you see
what I'm saying those houses are going
to look very different because they're
coming from your future and from your
future identity and so they're not going
to look the same as what you've been
doing in the past yeah it's been it's
been a challenge for me too so it's like
it's not uh maybe it's a challenge for
all of us because you know we all get
caught in our current situation and our
current momentum and and it's an
invitation to keep going to that next
level future and and operating from a
higher place and you know letting higher
opportunities come to us so it never
goes away by the way this whole process
continues is it bad if we actually don't
see our clinics we see our 100th texts
and we have it for that at that point I
think it's just semantics
um if you want to do that you can
um either way once you get there halfway
there you're going to be a different
person you're gonna be a different
person in three months from now and so
what you see in the future is going to
look different even in three months from
now I look at the past as a draft that
I'm continually redrafting you know
creating a better and better meaningful
past but also the future is a draft next
week I'm going to know a lot of things I
don't know right My Future Self even a
week from now is different than I know
and so I'll be able to clarify and
chisel the direction the vision all know
a lot of things in a week from now I
don't know today
yeah and and one of the things that I'm
picked up from Ben as well is to 2x you
can double your workload just double
your effort and you can get there but
the idea of going 10x or if you want to
do 100x you can't 100x or 10x your work
load so it forces you to think
differently and that's the whole point
like if you want it to grow by 10x or
12x or 23 and a half X or 100 or
whatever you just you have to think
differently and be doing different
things as opposed to and listen 2x is
still a great number for most people
right it's like if I doubled my business
like that's still a great number but a
lot of people do it by just doing more
of the same thing as opposed to saying
no like 80 of what I'm doing is why it's
scary 80 of what I'm doing will not help
me get to the next level so it
fundamentally shifts the work that you
have to do
yeah it's it's less about Brute Force
you know so like I I really like um I
love Steve Jobs you know this is why how
Dan and I conceptualized it in the book
is 10x is more of a qualitative
transformation more than a quantitative
one even though if you want to you know
do a quantitative jump right ten
thousand more subscribers you can do
that
um but it is qualitative in a lot of
ways because it transforms who you are
and how you do things that's why I use
the example of crawling to walking right
that's a qualitative change right so
Steve Jobs
what he did with music was qualitative
transformation he took what was the
music industry back then called back in
the 90s when he was inventing the iPod
right he reformed what music was right
um you know back then you had to go to
the store buy CDs at the store right if
you want one song you had to buy the
full album right and then you needed to
you know bring that home and you would
you know you'd have a whole bag of CDs
right and how much of that music did you
not want 80 at least 80 of it right and
so he said how do we get rid of all that
stuff right how do we remove the 80 and
how do we you know and so going from CDs
to an iPod is a qualitative
transformation right he didn't say how
can we sell 10 times more CDs right
that's Brute Force like that's that's
linear and as weird as it sounds he he
rethought how you know what would
actually change music such that
a million x the potential is there but
it's going to have to be changed it's
not it's not how can we make our horses
work 10 times harder how do we shift
from force and buggy to a car right and
so yeah it forces to think differently
and that's what the bigger future does
is it it's it's not about more in Brute
Force it's about uh making a shift a
transformation that's ultimately going
to enable unbelievable you know
potential that takes deep work to think
through that that's why you can't just
you know there's a great book and uh
Evan and I were talking about called
catching the big fish right and Evan was
talking about how he's he's he's going
fishing for some bigger fish right now
um catching the big fish is all about
meditation Consciousness and creativity
and he talks about how your attention
and your Consciousness is like the ocean
and if you're up at the surface is all
you can see is those small fish and so
you know to let go of those small fish
in kind of like a surface level
attention where you're just scraping the
surface caught in the 80 call it you
have to go deep and it's going deep in
seeing bigger fish
um that's where those Transformations
are that's where it's like oh this is a
totally different way of looking at this
is a totally different potential but
that takes deep work that takes creating
space
um in chapter five of the book we talk
about you know different models of time
you know like Dan obviously has his free
days and his Focus days concept uh
there's also someone named Paul Graham
Paul Graham's an amazing
um like entrepreneurial thinker and he
has what he calls either a maker
schedule or a manager schedule I think a
lot of people even entrepreneurs have
what Graham would call a manager
schedule where their time is like really
busy tons of meetings they jump from
thing to thing every hour right whereas
a maker schedule is like no you actually
have like four to eight hour blocks of
time to think right or to like solve a
problem like if you're a coder or if
you're creating something if you're
actually innovating something and
thinking through something right you
actually have to do some deep work to
connect some dots
um you can't just like scrape the
surface and be satisfied with you know
uh a surface level you know quick
dopamine hit like you actually if you're
gonna actually do 10 times more
important work 10 times better work
right you got to go deep and and kind of
break it down this is even what Elon
Musk talks about you know going down to
First principles breaking things apart
seeing how it works figuring out kind of
what you know what's possible and I
think that that's where you start to you
start to get a much higher return on
your attention so Dr Alan Bernard he
talks about it's not just about the
quality of your attention and certainly
we're talking about quality versus
quantity you know if you're focused on
quote unquote the 20 you're the quality
of your attention is going to be a lot
higher you're shifting from a quantity
of activity or quantity of things you're
focused on to equality but also Bernard
talks about return on attention where
it's like if I actually you know
like even just maybe read a great book
even this I'm guessing you guys being
here you're gonna get a big return on
this attention right you could have just
spent the day busy but like this might
change how you think about things and so
you're gonna get a big return on
attention for the ongoing future right
but um even you know so like if if I'm
sitting and I'm focusing on something
and I'm really thinking through
something I might not get the immediate
return
of something where I could just surface
quick level get a quick dopamine hit but
the return on my attention might pay
dividends for the rest of my life where
it's like I actually
figured something out or learn something
or just worked on something that you
know I moved forward on as an example
like I spent you know call it a year
working on this yes it changed how I
think it changed how I write but also
just it is uh it is a thing that's going
to be out in the world and so like I'm
gonna get a return on this on the
attention I put into making this book
I'm gonna get a return on that attention
for the rest of my life even if not
quantitatively even if the book goes out
of stock or stops selling in 10 years
and like quantitatively I stopped
getting royalties qualitatively
I'm a different person because I
actually went through the process of
figuring out some of these ideas not
that they're perfect My Future Self will
think a lot differently about them but
um the return on your attention is
really what you start to get when you
start to get big big things out of it
and so that's also part of I think the
weak design is like what's the greatest
return on my time and attention what's
going to be the thing that continues to
pay my future self long into the future
because I spent that that day doing it
and think about relationships you know
I've got six kids right so like I get a
huge return on attention when I invest
time just being present with my kids
like that's something that
pays me for the rest of my life all
right we went deep there thank you man
let's go Francesca what's your question
uh I am one question that uh for sure
can help all of us
um Ben what you said it's for sure uh
really a transmutation of energy okay
you go in four-dimensional take what you
wanted then you transformed into the
inventional
but how you deal with this in practice
in really practice
for example I studied this material for
many years to study with Bob Proctor for
many years so I want to understand
how you deal with this for example when
you say okay you work from the end from
your ideal self okay let's make an
example
you wanna act from 10x okay what you do
mentally and practically in the mental
space and in three-dimensional space in
the in the material space you act as the
person you want to become let's start it
simple
um first off back to that quote I shared
from Dan earlier which is entrepreneurs
who are too tightly scheduled don't have
the space if you're too tightly
scheduled right and this doesn't have to
be just entrepreneurs I think anyone who
you know even in the book essentialism
Greg McEwen talks about the importance
of creating space so that you can
actually clarify the priority right and
so I think part of Designing for this to
be a regular process not a one-time
thing where you get clarity in Now You
Gotta for me you know back to even Evan
designing around going on long walks or
something like that you were saying that
becomes part of the process where you're
constantly kind of in meditation
thinking about clarifying your future
self you know analyzing your current
life thinking hard through the things
you got to let go of strategizing like
having space to think
um to journal to reflect to have key
conversations with people who you can
kind of even get clear on and open up
about decisions you're considering
making I think having that be built in
to your life and just having you know
creating space for that where that's a
continuous process of clarifying
thinking about it
um I Journal about things I Journal
about you know what you know if you
looked at my journal I flew to Phoenix
from Orlando
I was thinking about you know where do I
want to be in five years what about 12
months from now what's important in 10
years right and like it's just again
back to the idea of it being a draft if
you're writing the draft of a book it's
okay if the draft is incomplete it's
okay if you know that in a week from now
the draft might totally change right
it's a draft and so but by working on
the draft you've got something to riff
off of and so by drafting it's just
really nice you can you can update the
draft you can improve it you you might
and so there's nothing wrong with just
thinking it through talking about it you
know and then once you get clear and
clear on it you use that as just part of
your decision making process you know as
an example uh you know and you you set
shorter term things you know so for me
for example like you know I am
interested in YouTube it might be
something I let go of in the future but
you know as I'm thinking about my future
stuff I'm like yeah so I think I'll uh
commit to trying to make a video a month
in May right that might be a short-term
strategy that I Implement that I may
achieve perfectly or imperfectly and
maybe you know maybe at the end of the
month I'll say you know I'm gonna go for
something a little different there so I
think what you're trying to get to is
you're trying to get to like immediate
Clarity ultimate Clarity into like
Fully live it and be it today and I'm
saying it's more of a process like you
know it's but you can use the few so so
you know you could you could be better
as your future self today than you were
yesterday and you could maybe check the
aspect of your past self out more and
then you might come up with plans
short-term plans or strategies to run
for it you know maybe you reach out to
someone
um and you're just continually doing it
better and better on a daily weekly
monthly basis you know it's not just
like a one-time shift change now you're
your future self and like forever you
know it's it's a constant process of
evolution one thing's the the more for
example did you believe that it's
something that is really correlated to
belief system example I want to share
this with you
when I started to follow my mentor 15
years ago the first thing that I asked
him is what about business plan
and he said me I don't have a business
plan and he made
100 millions and where I said how how
this is possible
and he said because I don't believe in
business plan
then I went to another mentor and he
said oh Francesco it's it's impossible
to make money without business plan so
finally I I deducted this that it's all
about belief system because for example
if I got an ax might an X as you say
this subject is subjectively it's
important yeah your tanks may be
irrelevant to me right but it's
important to yep
yeah and so what I believe is what I
want to ask you is this did you believe
that it's about belief system
that for example for the logo OR
reversibility
that with your psychological if you
change psychologically you can change
also physically so if you change
physically you can change them
psychologically
for you it's possible to think
that it's all about belief can I ask you
a question real quick what is the answer
you want me to give you this is kind of
a funny question obviously you've
thought about this for years
and maybe I can give an Insight that you
haven't gotten and I'm happy to try but
I'm just wondering what is it that
you're ultimately trying to get at with
this question
that it's all about belief system
when you say belief system right
um is that so for example I have a
different belief system than Evan right
yeah which means that the things that
I'm going to care about worry about and
go for and also my own process of going
about it it's going to be very different
from heaven right
yeah
and so is that is that what you're
talking about where it's like I have a
belief system I also have a value system
about what matters to me and that's
going to influence quote unquote the the
purposes that I go strive to fulfill
right I might think that this is the
most important thing that I could do
with my life based on my belief system
and then I'll I go for that and that
might from Evan's perspective not be
interesting at all right is that what
you're talking about
yes this is this is what I want I also I
think part of that belief system would
be similar to like growth mindset versus
fixed mindset right do I believe I
actually can change and become my future
self right do I believe that I can find
the right people right so yeah there are
elements of of course your your your
belief system is going to shape not only
what you go for but how you go for it
and hopefully you're constantly
transforming that belief system you know
so that it's more useful more valuable
um more empowering and so yeah you have
a belief system I have a belief system
uh they're all flawed right there's a
quote from Stephen Covey essentially
where he said we don't see the world as
it is we see the world as we are right
so you think the world through your
belief system you see the world through
your mental models and uh I think it's
really important to analyze those
there's even psychologists who explain
ways in which you can get out of your
belief system and actually analyze it
critically and see where there's
weaknesses in it
um and it takes a lot of emotional
development so like I know that I
believe things very differently than I
believed even like a year ago or even um
five years ago right I know that my
future self is going to believe and care
about things that I don't
understand right now or care about right
and so I think you know yes the belief
system matters a lot but for me
hopefully it's constantly getting better
or you know at least it's transforming
and that's how I think about that let's
bring up Jovana and then maybe have some
final thoughts from Ben let's see what
giovanna's got for us hi good morning
everybody thank you so much of course
this is mind-blowing really awesome and
it's just peeling away a lot of stuff
and I'm like wow like um I just did this
yesterday and today I'm like I just
scheduled something that is not in
alignment with what I want there you go
great cash very good catch you gotta let
those things go
I mean no but no no but
um
yeah you can say yeah it's scary to let
go of things yeah I'm an actor so we
can't say but right in improv we always
have to say and right so it's like
I am an actor and I turned off there I
wrote this book teen anxiety no more and
it has just become my heart and my
everything and My Future Self what I
want to do
and being an actor you're always told
like persistence don't quit waiters
never win winners never quit so now do
you have any steps or suggestions on how
I can overcome that like oh my gosh you
know maybe I'm quitting all my acting
which isn't what I feel like I'm doing I
feel like I'm I'm wanting to 10x but
that internal struggle of like is it
quitting am I quitting because I don't
know does that make sense
well let me just ask you this is your
future self more you know is your future
self still acting or are you mostly
doing stuff with the books if you're
honest with yourself all progress starts
by telling the truth
and you could say they're doing both I'm
just wondering you know what do you you
know you're not quitting something if if
your future is inviting you to Let It Go
I mean it's not like you're you're
quitting because think about it think
about it you're only if you quit
something because you still want it but
you're giving up that's different than
letting something go because it's no
longer relevant
like letting go of something because the
future is inviting you to let it go is
not the same as quitting something that
you're giving up on because you've
failed you've stopped believing in
yourself right like if I have a real if
I have a massive dream of accomplishing
something and I'm on my way and I'm
breaking myself down and and I
eventually just get to some point where
I throw in the towel and settle for less
one of my favorite goal uh quotes by the
way
um this quote says this is from Robert
bralt
he said we're kept from our goal not by
obstacles but by a clear path to a
lesser goal
so let me say it again listen we're kept
from our goal not by obstacles but by a
clear path to a lesser goal
lesser goal so listen oh I know I know
listen one sec
so often when we're going towards our
goal and we're hitting obstacles often
we take a clear path to a lesser goal we
give up or we shift to some 80 that's
comfortable right and so you know you
have to ask yourself so I don't think
it's quitting
if you have a goal
and you let go of lesser goals to get
there sometimes your lesser goals are
those 80 percent that were really
valuable in the past right blogging for
me became a lesser goal uh staying in
certain groups became a lesser goal
right where it's like yeah or hopping on
social media instead of focusing or
being with my kids is a lesser goal
we're all you know and so if you are
really clear in your future self
you just gotta say you know what am I
gonna let go of so that I can go through
the process of becoming my future self
and sometimes the things you gotta let
go of those lesser goals are things that
really mattered to your past self maybe
acting becomes a lesser goal right I'm
not saying it is you know only you know
your future self and what you want but
letting go of those lesser goals is
massive evidence that you're committing
more and more to the Future that you
want so every time you peel away and let
go of some of that 80 let go of some of
those lesser goals you're demonstrating
to yourself that you're being really
serious about your future self that
you're committing to that
wow that is so cool
it doesn't like it removes some of that
way right it's like we have this
heaviness around this is absorbing it so
what did you get out of that I want to
hear what you just what you just
digested
that releasing things actually serves
you
says um
to your true Future Self
yeah that is like beautifully
um framed it just really opens things up
instead of limiting you to think in you
know away have you ever read the book by
the way have you ever read the book by
Seth Godin called the dib no no Seth
Godin wrote a little book you could read
the whole thing in an hour called the
dip and he talks about the idea that
Winners never quit and quitters never
win
is a lie you know it's a myth
um he says winners quit all the time
they just quit the right the right stuff
at the right time you know so like I
quit blogging does that mean I'm a loser
no I just quit the right thing you know
but but I utilized it really deeply when
it made sense to My Future Self you know
um there's a lot of things that I'm
gonna have to let go of I really think
going 10x is likely just as much or even
more about what you let go of that 80
those lesser goals right
um that old identity those former
commitments uh it's more about honestly
what you let go of so that you can then
create the space to go deep on where
you're now going to go
yeah I love that that's amazing and
acting got me here because I wrote the
book because of my acting ironically
enough so it's just like having that
like you gotta just be honest about
yourself and your future self and I
think that uh that level of honesty can
be scary for people you know and you
know uh maybe maybe in the future you
will want to either get back into acting
or maybe becoming a bigger actor or
doing various types of roles becomes
really important to you maybe right now
this is what you're being called to it's
kind of that Call to Adventure right
this is what you're being called to and
there's a resistance to the call and an
invitation back to lesser goals you're
80 that's safe and comfortable your
security blanket
um
and you know you don't have to peel it
all away at once I think that that was
what we were talking about earlier like
you could certainly if there's certain
things that you just know I'm gonna hold
on to this because I'm scared and yeah
maybe you could let go that meeting
right
um and you realize oh like
one of the things that and I hit this in
the book there's a concept called loss
aversion and in in in in pychology
there's a lot of research that shows
that humans are a lot more driven to
avoid loss than to seek gain in other
words losses feel more painful than
gains feel good right
and so like our brains are really
designed to avoid loss right like we
what we end up doing is we end up
inflating the potential risks and
downsides way out of proportion right so
it's like oh if I if I don't go to that
meeting like you know we start to create
these worst case scenarios when like in
reality it's kind of like think about
when you're wanting to go ask your boss
for a raise right or something like that
like we start projecting out all of
these crazy worst case scenarios when
when eventually we go and do it we
realize ah
wasn't that bad right you know
distinction that came through for me
today in listening to you talk versus
just reading the book was that the the
80 that you're
that you need to let go to get the 10x
will fight for its existence deep
intensely not only on the psychological
side that's your former identity but
also situationally
um you know people don't want you know
you're also by you changing like you're
going to require them to change and you
know like whether that's letting go of
an employee or you know whether that's
changing your relationship it's going to
heavily defend itself
yeah and so that that's uh maybe it is
in there I mean and maybe just the way
you worded it today just as a
distinction for me that you not only the
people around you might fight you or
clients might not be happy that you're
now leaving them and don't worry yeah
abandoned or right they'll have their
own story but also you yourself like
there's parts of yourself most of
yourself is actually fighting against
you to become the 10x version of you uh
and so to expect the resistance and then
work through it so there's a really
really good book on the subject and
maybe the stuff's coming out cleaner
because honestly I've studied this a lot
since writing the book you know I
finished the book like six months ago
and I've been studying this but there's
a Harvard psychologist named Robert
Keegan he has a book called immunity to
change
um and so what you're talking about is
the built-in immunities we have to
changing we actually psychologically
have built-in immunities to the changes
we want so like for example let's just
say I want to achieve X goal well I have
these massive immunities
to making that change and the and and
what he calls basically it's your
subconscious by the way but
um it's he calls it in this book hidden
commitments and limiting beliefs so you
have commitments and they're hidden to
you um their commitments to your former
self made these are your pass off so
commitment is a big part of identity so
you have commitments that are keeping
you in that 80 maybe you have a
commitment to being really loyal right
and and so like that's going to keep you
uh in certain relationships that you now
know right and I'm not saying loyalty is
bad I'm just saying you start to when
you start to observe yourself
resisting these changes that you want to
make and you see yourself staying in
situations opportunities that you like
already know it's kind of like it
doesn't resonate anymore you start to
ask well what is the hidden commitment I
have that's keeping me here it's my
immunity to the change I want and so we
have these hidden commitments that keep
us doing the things that we've done or
in the situations or the relationships
and um when you start peeling those away
you start to say yeah this was a con
concept or an idea that might pass off
really believed in and really you know
was really important to them which is
why it makes so much sense why I'm why
this is hard for me to let go of yeah so
yeah it's it's it's it's your past self
your past identity you know and your
past you know commitments and beliefs
that make it really those are the
immunities to the change you want those
are the things that are defending itself
from you moving on and shifting these
things and going deep onto the next
stage so your past self is defending
itself against your future self I love
it the book is 10x is easier than 2x so
I'm going to go pick that up
uh it's my favorite book of the year as
I said at the beginning I've I've
chunked out a lot of pages I get a lot
of books this one is legit and
two minutes final message please go buy
the book please whether it's the
audiobook of the book whether you listen
or read as soon as you get it please go
through the introduction as fast as you
can
from there if it doesn't blow you away
throw it away seriously read the
introduction no seriously I'm promising
you
um you'll hear the story we were talking
about Michelangelo and his various 10xes
and then you'll see kind of how this
idea is is truly in a lot of ways the
opposite of how how many of us have
thought about this idea and then that
sets the stage for the book and I I said
the book is obviously you know I think
it'll be very valuable to anyone in this
group
um so yeah I guess my just ask for my
invitation is please get the book please
read it if you love it share it um but
first things first get it and either
listen to or read the introduction as
fast as possible and then from there you
can decide what you'll do next with it
who knows what will happen in the future
but hopefully this is a valuable
conversation and uh yeah I would just
say putting it in simple terms uh your
your 10x future self is the David right
and to become the David you have to
strip away everything that's not your
10x feature self which is the 80 of your
past self that uh is to be celebrated
right letting go of the 80 initially
feels you know you can have negative
emotion towards letting that go right
you could have frustration anger
um disappointment grieving right a
seeming loss um really what you're doing
is you're stripping away and opening up
the space and so letting go of the 80 is
to be celebrated it celebrated what it
was you celebrate what it was I
celebrate blogging it was amazing I
celebrate the relationships that brought
me here but now you know there's no
longer alignment on the next 10x and I
said you want to celebrate the past you
want to celebrate the 80 as you let it
go it's it's actually a gain that you're
letting it go it's not a gap it's not a
loss
um it's truly a game that you're letting
this go but you can celebrate it it can
be framed beautifully and positively and
uh so to go 10x
it's a tight filter it's a massive
filter that's gonna just like my son
with tennis less options to 10x you know
that those less options are your 80 that
you're gonna have to strip away and then
you're gonna have to go deep on the few
things that have 10x potential and
you're going to become a 10x Master
deeper at what you do and so it's just
an invitation to Mastery an invitation
to stripping away everything that's not
your your David which is your purest
self if you 10x feature yourself so hope
you enjoy it it's been happy to be here
love this guy and uh back to you guys
all soon love being with you if you want
to join us in movement makers check the
link in the description below otherwise
enjoy this video right here I think
you'll love it